the rapid spread of measles is prompting
newer and stronger measures from health
officials across the country when the
CDC says the number of cases has grown
to 555 in 20 states this year he's on
track to be the worst year for the DS
disease since health officials said it
was eradicated in - in 2000 suburban
Rockland County New York is among the
hardest hit areas with 186 cases since
October mostly in the ultra-orthodox
Jewish community
Mulla lanky is outside a synagogue in
Spring Valley New York with Rockland
counties aggressive response Mullah good
morning good morning while Rockland
counties first emergency order banning
unvaccinated people from public spaces
is currently being challenged in court
the county has issued a new order aimed
at people already infected with measles
as the virus spreads from New York into
other states officials say it is an
emergency
that requires action now despite our
best efforts this outbreak is not going
away if anything is now accelerating
much as we feared executive eda implored
people in Rockland County to help
reverse the troubling trend Tuesday he
announced that all people infected with
measles must avoid public places and
stay in their homes for 21 days failure
to comply will result in a fine of
$2,000 per violation per day to say we
are overreaching flies in the face of
fact history and the most important
common-sense the rapidly growing
outbreak in New York is centered around
ultra-orthodox Jewish communities both
in Rockland County and in Brooklyn but
the impact there is now spreading beyond
the state last month a man who had
visited New York drove to Michigan and
accidentally infected 38 other people
with the disease he says he was unaware
he had contracted measles which is so
contagious that if one person has it up
to 90% of the people close to that
person who are not immune will also
become infected common symptoms include
a high fever a cough and a red rash are
there concerns that it will continue to
spread absolutely there are concerns
that it's going to continue to spread
doctor Alana Levine is a pediatrician in
Rockland County who says preventing
disease should always come before
having to treat it this is a disease
that was eliminated from the United
States in the year 2000 it's
unbelievable to me as a pediatrician
that I'm now having to worry about my
patients coming down with the measles it
seems like we're going backwards it
feels like we're going backwards in time
now just because you don't have the
virus doesn't mean you can't spread it
those initial symptoms can often seem
like the common cold infected people can
spread the virus from four days before
through four days after that initial red
rash appears so Galle that is why
officials are really demanding that
people get vaccinated immediately to
stop the spread of this virus all right
well that's very good advice but so many
people are not listening it is it is
amazing in 2019 that we were talking
about a measles oh it's a great
reporting great report by mola and I'm
fascinated how in the face is what is
unequivocal science absolutely clear the
vaccines are safe you need to get this
that there's still a belief that they
are and I think we need to figure out
where this news is coming from where the
spread of information that's sort of
infecting our knowledge base mm-hmm
well and as the psychologists who look
at this say people who hold these views
when you present them with facts often
they double down on their view which
makes it entrenched and so it's a hard
hard thing to get at to is a public
health health issue
no meantime people are getting very hurt
and sick you need to think about that